hey guys let's talk about energy drinks
by now you've probably heard a lot of
people tell you oh don't drink energy
drinks because it is bad for you but
have you ever just stopped and seriously
think about this is it really bad for
your health and if it is bad how bad
what can it do to your body that's what
we're going to talk about in this video
let's not waste more time let's get to
it foreign
all right guys now I'm actually making
this video for a good friend of mine you
know who you are
that needs to watch this video about
energy drinks and please I hope this is
sinking in
let's start with the facts because the
truth is all that matters in the last
few years energy drinks have become more
and more popular and people are starting
to drink them almost like water drinking
one energy drink after the other and
these companies are making a fortune
according to statista.com energy drinks
are one of the top selling packaged
beverages in the United States in 2019
energy drinks accounted for 31 of the
dollar sales of packaged beverages sold
at the U.S convenience stores energy
drink sales in the United States reached
around 14 billion dollars in 2021. Red
Bull is the best selling brand of energy
drink by a large margin in 2020 Red Bull
sales reached 2.9 billion US Dollars
monster was the second leading energy
drink brand in the United States that
year generating sales of 1.76 billion
USD dollars so how big has this Market
actually grown according to men's
health.com the energy drink Market has
grown to over 400 percent in just five
years
now let me be honest with you your
energy drink is not just a quick energy
booster it is actually a nutritional
time bomb
and if you actually care about your
health about your body because you only
get one in this world that's it
if you care about your body you need to
stop drinking it now
let me give you four facts of what I
mean
[Music]
sugar is the number one drug in the
world causing chronic health conditions
like cancer diabetes and heart disease
to mention just a few
a lot of people these days complain
about inflammation sugar gives you
inflammation
according to insider.com the Heart
Association only recommends 36 grams of
sugar a day for men
by that measure a 24 ounce energy drink
has tripled the amount of sugar
recommended in a day
now when you drink this much sugar I
mean it's triple the amount you need in
a day so then you eat all the other food
as well so you get all that sugar in but
let's just go back to the drink so you
triple the amount there you go one drink
your body struggles to control all that
sugar
that gives you high blood sugar which
then damages your nerves and blood
vessels over time and this will then
give you a heart disease and even kidney
problems well let me not say for sure it
will happen let me just say that the
chances are very high it's very likely
now for you guys who want to lose weight
you need to stay away from energy drinks
because if you habitually drink energy
drinks it can prevent you your body from
burning fat glucose is the sugar your
body breaks carbs down into it goes
straight into your bloodstream
so when you go and you give your body
that energy drink with all that Sugar
your body goes crazy Red Bull has 27
grams of sugar in a normal 250
milliliter scan that's Seven teaspoons
monster has 54 grams in 473 milliliters
that's 14 teaspoons of sugar
so when that goes into your system your
body stops burning fat it stops
everything and it tries for dear life to
handle all of that sugar but it can't
because it's too much and then if you
add caffeine to it which most well
almost all energy drinks have it's just
a recipe for disaster for example Red
Bull contains 80 milligrams per 250
milliliters monster 142 milligrams at
473 milliliters now caffeine already
gives your body an energy boost just
like the caffeine you get from coffee I
actually have coffee here wait one
second
see already empty already drank it well
there's a little bit left
so when you then combine the caffeine
with the sugar
your body turns into a spiced rocket
because it fires up
only to come crashing down again and
that's why you feel tired all the time
and that's why some guys go and drink
another one because now they feel tired
so they drink another one up energy
comes down crashes again and they feel
like man I'm so tired and I blame it on
all the other things maybe their work or
their stress or whatever it might be and
it's actually all about their diet
and guys please listen to me today this
is not good for your heart according to
theinsider.com in the U.S more than 20
000 emergency room visits in 2011 were
associated with energy drink use
a small 2014 review found that out of 11
patients with serious heart problems
including Cardiac Arrest five reported
heavy energy drink consumption
all right
energy for the short term
serious health conditions for the long
term people who usually Focus only on
the now and don't care about the future
tend to experience a whole lot of
problems as time goes by it's not very
smart to live that way because if you
don't plan for the future as I always
say you plan to fail and that's the same
for your body your body will fail and
you only get one
it is your decision but you will have to
be okay content with the consequences of
your decisions as well if you choose to
give in to your emotions to just feel
good to drink energy drink for the now
just for the taste or just for the
energy you think you need you will also
have to deal with the energy crashing
part because what goes up must come down
and then you'll also have to deal with
all the possible other wide range of
conditions like
sleep deprivation weight gain or bad
blood pressure and then there's
overarching evidence that suggests that
energy drinks may lead to substance
abuse mental health problems a higher
diabetes risk tooth decay and kidney
damage according to men's health.com
are you willing to deal with chronic
health conditions until the day you die
only for a few energy drinks now
I'm not
[Music]
it is more harmful to teenagers and
young adults according to the nccih
energy drinks increase the risk of
several health conditions for teens and
young adults including cardiovascular
nervous system anomalies cognitive
underdevelopment increased risk of
depression and other mental health
illnesses and Sleep Disorders now you
would think that these companies would
know the risks of these energy drinks to
teens and young adults
the truth is they do and they don't care
and we see that in their marketing
because despite
these health risks for teens and young
adults the marketing is specifically for
them for young people well not
specifically but it is heavily marketed
to young people
see through the cracks you need to look
at the truth whenever you look at any
form of marketing from food or drink
companies you need to be able to see the
truth some companies will over emphasize
certain parts or points of their product
so that you don't see
the questionable Parts rut poison is 99
good food but it is the one percent that
kills
you know some people told me but Daniel
it's good for you it gives you energy
and it's got B vitamins so energy drinks
that's good for you it's not a bad come
on
well yes Red Bull liquisate and V Energy
Drinks all contain B vitamins but the
bad stuff doesn't just suddenly
disappear because of it because that's
just like saying hey hamburgers is now
healthy because it's got tomato and
lettuce on it
it's still unhealthy according to the
National Center for complementary and
Integrative Health a growing body of
scientific evidence shows that energy
drinks can have serious health effects
particularly in children teenagers and
young adults
another question that you need to ask
yourself is this and I won't judge
because everybody has a right to make
their own decisions you just have to
deal with those consequences ask
yourself this question
is it worth it for me it's definitely
not
if you want to know how to have more
energy
then learn how to live a healthy
lifestyle check out this video here and
we'll help you out before you go always
remember life is short
so don't waste yours just guys